قالت مصادر امنيه صوماليه ان انفجاراين
وقع في فندق روز بالقرب من القصر الرئاسي
في العاصمه مقديشو واضافت المصادر ان
مسلحين يرتدون احزمه ناسفه هاجموا الفندق
الذي يقيم فيه نواب في البرلمان ومسؤولون
في الحكومه ويقع ضمن دائره حمايه قصر
الرئاسي المحصنه وقالت الشرطه الصوماليه
ان الاجهزه الامنيه نجحت في انقاذ
المسؤولين في الحكومه والمواطنين داخل
الفندق وقد اعلنت حركه الشباب المجاهدين
مسؤليتها عن الهجوم وفق ما نشره موقع
محسوب على الحركه
وتبعت لهذا الانفجار معانا بالمقديشي
مراسل الجزيره جامع نور جامع ماذا عن هذا
التفجير وماذا خلفه والتعامل معه حتى الان
عبد القادر الى هذه اللحظه وحسب شهود عيان
في المنطقه التي وقع فيها الهجوم لا زالت
هناك اشتباكات وتبادل الاطلاق النار بين
الاجهزه الامنيه الصوماليه وبين العناصر
المهاجمه التي تتحسن داخل هذا الفندق كما
قالت شرطه الصوماليه فان الاجهزه الامنيه
استطاعت ان تخرج المسؤولين الحكوميين
والنواب وكل من كان بداخل هذا الفندق الذي
يقع من ما ذكرتهم في منطقه محصنه وتعد
الحزام الامني بالنسبه للقصر الرئاسي وهي
من المناطق المهمه حيث الوزارات الحكوميه
والبرلمان الصومالي والقصر الرئاسي وايضا
هناك منازل همم التي يسكنها مسؤولون في
الحكومه الصوماليه هذا الانفجار همم لا
توجد حتى الان معلومات رسميه واضحه لانه
همم من الصعب على الاعلاميين الوصول الى
هذه النقطه التي يطلب كل من يصل اليها ان
تكون انت اخو البطاقه حكوميه وغيره وغير
ومن لا ومن لا يحمل هذه البطاقه الحكوميه
لا يستطيع الوصول الى هذه المناطق همم كل
المعلومات المتوفره لدينا هي ان الاجهزه
الامنيه لا زالت تجري هناك مواجهات ما بين
الاجهزه الامنيه
والمقتحمين الذين دخلوا في هذا الفندق اما
بالنسبه لما يتعلق بطبيعه هذا الانفجار
هناك تضارب في الروايات هناك من يتحدث انه
ناتج عن همم الرجال كانوا يلبسون احزمه
همم ناسفه همم فجروا انفسهم في البوابه
الرئيسيه للفندق وبعدها قاموا باقتحامه
هناك من يتحدث ان الانفجار الاول هو
ناتج عن سياره وفققه استهدفت البوابه
الرئيسيه للفندق وبعد ذلك حدث هذا
الانفجار ودخله هناك بعض الانباء التي
تشير يعني الى اصابه وزير الامن الصوماليه
بجروح في رجله وانه نقل الى المستشفى
500 من قبل الحدث الذي مازال مستمر
حتى الان جامع نور من مقديش شكرا جزيلا لك